Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg
congressional testimony highlighted the
debate over how much tech company should
protect your data your digital footprint
goes far beyond social media sites like
Facebook cloud fair is a global service
that offers protection from hackers and
faster speeds to more than 7 million
websites it serves more web traffic than
Twitter Amazon Apple Instagram Bing and
Wikipedia combined now cloud fair is out
with a new product aimed at consumers
the company believes this will make it
more difficult for businesses to track
your internet activity CloudFlare it
also says it can speed up your overall
service online Matthew Prince is the CEO
Matthew good morning good morning so
talk about this service that you provide
Clough lers core service is to make the
internet faster and safer for anyone
who's trying to put any kind of content
or service online but what we announced
recently with our new 1.1 1.1 service
which is a lot of ones is that we can
help consumers protect a little bit of
their data from leaking to ISPs and
other businesses that might be tracking
them on the Internet
and we're excited to be providing this
to services and for the first time offer
it to consumers before we break this
down what does one dot one dot one dot
one stand for other than just for ones
in a row well one of the things that's
hard about the internet is that your
computer doesn't know google.com or
amazon.com and so it has to look to a
directory almost like the white pages
for the internet to figure out the
address of where that is and what one
dot one dot one dot one for ones is is
it's a service that provides that
directory and speeds it up for your
actual browsing and make sure that your
your information isn't being tracked
online and one of the takeaways from the
hearings that we saw with Mark
Zuckerberg this week is that there seem
to be a disconnect between Congress and
the tech world right some of the
questions imply that there's not much
understanding as to what these tech
companies do how important is that for
you to relay to users because to
understand being hacked would mean to
understand your service in
all right yeah I think that you know the
the thing which is important for
consumers to understand is that there
are some tech companies that sell
products companies like CloudFlare and
Apple and then there are some tech
companies that actually sell you as the
user and your attention to advertisers
and technology isn't inherently about
compromising privacy or protecting
privacy it really depends on what the
tech tech company's business model is
and CloudFlare our business model is to
make sure the internet is fast and
protected from hackers and scammers and
so it was very aligned with us to say we
don't want to sell our customers data
our users data for advertising because
that's that's just never been a part of
our business model and so it's it's not
easy enough to say that tech is pro or
anti privacy I think you have to look at
an ax company by company basis so what
is the business model how does
CloudFlare make money we service
customers who pay us to use our global
network which spans a hundred and fifty
cities around the world to make the
internet faster and again protect them
from hackers and scammers online and so
everyone from small businesses up to you
know some of the world's largest
companies use our network in order to
ensure that they're fast and that their
services are always available but the
thing is Mathew consumers are of two
minds about privacy too when it comes to
finding a restaurant in their
neighborhood they're irritated when the
app doesn't already anticipate where
they live and can find the restaurants
next to them if it says to them hey will
you tell us where you live so we can
give you the restaurants they say oh
sure and it's all those little tiny
little decisions that then when they're
aggregating people say oh my gosh I've
given away my whole life but in a lot of
ways they've given it because they want
the the the ease of use so isn't that
the what the tension is here in terms of
consumer privacy you know I think what
the hearings showed is that consumers
often don't understand when they're
being tracked online for instance when
we launch 1.1.1 to one people were
surprised to know that not only could
ISPs see every website that you went to
online but actually that Congress
relaxed the rules and allowed them to
then sell that browsing data to
advertisers
and so I think what's really important
is that there's clarity across all of
the tech industry of what data is being
captured and that you give consumers the
ability to actually opt out of that
information if they don't want that
information to be now I'm so glad you
brought that up because I think in sort
of this outrage over privacy every
single web search that we make that
information can be sold right just in a
simple that's right and I think that
consumers don't understand that and we
frame this around privacy but I think
what consumers really want is control
they want to be able to say this is my
data I understand who I'm giving it to
sometimes when I give that data to them
they can put a a service can provide a
better experience to me but I don't want
it to feel it's creepy when you know the
handbag that you are looking at online
or the pair of shoes starts following
you around the internet we've all had
that experience that's right so let me
ask you about regulation then because
it's something that the tech industry
shunned for years up until now right
even heard Mike Mark Zuckerberg say that
he would agree to some that was valuable
regarding the details how do you feel
about the subject matter and what effect
do you think the government could have
an implementing proper regulation you
know I think that regulation is an
important for any industry including the
tech industry but it's important to get
that right and what's tough is whenever
there's new technology that comes along
whether that was the telephone or
television or or now the internet it
takes a while for social norms and
understandings to develop and then once
you have those you can start to put
together regulations so I think that you
know like Mark Zuckerberg like I think
most of the tech industry we don't
welcome sensible regulation that talks
about things like being transparent
about what data is being collected about
you knowing that you can get that data
back from the providers that you that
you offer it to and for us you know
that's easy for us to support because
again that's never been our business
model and so I think that a lot of the
tech industry would actually you know
welcome what was really sensible in like
regulation because we're tech users
ourselves and it creeps me
when my data is flowing across the
internet all right we're gonna have to
leave it there Matthew thank you so much